now here's the thing I would have
thought Harris support that you wouldn't
like these sorts of award Bashers but
you would never go but you do go don't
you on on the rare occasions I've got
anything to do with it yeah
it's usually a presenting an award
that's an honor is it
Then I then I've won
because at Margot Shield but she won't
tell it but she is an enormous Harrison
Ford fan it's true isn't it yeah
so this is your intervention
thank you of that notion
and you'll help oh don't you worry I can
count on him
I have to admit something Harrison um
though Indiana Jones is like one of the
most iconic characters ever
um my favorite movie that you're in is
actually Six Days Seven Nights
very good movie if no one's seen it
available thank you
I hope so
I should stay on this side I'm getting
too excited I have a bunch of DVDs in
the back of my car
I'll meet you out in the street
oh you saw it
[Applause]
[Music]